- Like it's a dream to win a championship,
but it's a dream to have the ball in your hands when the buzzer goes off.
I knew I was keeping it.
Like, I wasn’t gonna throw it.
Like, sometimes you see, like, people, like, throw it.
- You see Kobe do that?
- Yeah, throw it up and all that.
I'm like, "Nah, I'm keeping this. I don't care what happens.”
♪♪♪
[Master Tesfatsion:] So, who we got in the pool hall today?
Oh, we got Coach Kara Lawson. What’s up?
- [Kara Lawson:] [Laughing]
- DMV’s finest. How you living?
- Doing good. Great.
- You're one of the nicest players in the DMV,
but how nice are you on the pool table?
-  Uh, I'm, I'm OK.
- [Laughing]
- Needs work. Needs work. But we’ll try.
- Let's see what you can do.
Let’s see what you can do on the break.
There we go.
You spent the majority of your time in the WNBA
with the Sacramento Monarchs, but you were drafted by the Shock.
- Yeah.
- What happened on draft night?
- Well, I get drafted. And it's exciting, obviously.
My mom, my dad, excited about getting drafted.
Bill Laimbeer was the coach of the Shock at the time.
I get on the phone and Laimbeer's like,
"Yeah we're about to, we're gonna trade you."
- [Laughing]
- Like, he didn't say like, "Congrats," or like, or like anything, you know?
He's just like, "Yeah, we're working on a
trade so you're not gonna be here with us."
I'm like, “Welcome to the league.”
- [Laughing]
What do you remember, day one, when you got to Sacramento?
What do you recall from that moment?
- I'd never been to Sacramento.
So day one, I remember getting picked up at the airport
and people that have been in the league, NBA, WNBA,
like, there was nothing in Sacramento.
- [Laughing]
- Like, now it's different.
Some people still might say there's nothing
in Sacramento, but I love Sacramento.
But then, it was like fields and, like, ARCO in the middle of nothing.
- [Laughing]
- I was like, "Where am I?”
- I grew up in the DMV, went to school at Tennessee.
That was just an adjustment,
being out on your own for the first time now.
Hey.
Strong shot.
- That 2005 run,
what was your favorite game that you recall from that moment?
- Probably the close-out game. Probably Game 4.
- How was ARCO that game?
- ARCO was crazy.
It was so loud.
You know, they had never won a championship in the city before.
That was our last chance to do it there
cuz we didn't have home-court in that series.
We played 1 and 2 on the road. We played 3 and 4 at home.
So to close it out there at home in front of our fans was amazing.
[Balls hitting, ball dropping into pocket]
- Well, with 0.4 seconds left.
- Mhmm.
- Quick inbound to you.
- Yeah.
- Clock goes triple zero.
- How are you feeling?
- I was feeling great.
Like, it's a dream to win a championship,
but it's a dream to have the ball in your hands when the buzzer goes off.
And, so, I knew I was keeping it.
Any picture you find of me that night,
I got the ball in my hand cuz I didn't want anybody to take it.
And then, I had everybody on the team sign it.
And I still have that ball.
-  So you guys win the championship in 2005,
and then you're the first pro women's team on a Wheaties box.
What does that mean? Do you still have that box too or no?
- I still have it in a case at my mom's house.
That cereal's gone, you know.
- [Laughing]
- Can't have that around for 15 years.
- But I still have the boxes, yeah. It was really cool.
Growing up, being on a Wheaties box was like, I mean that was it.
- Yeah.
So your final year in Sacramento was in 2009,
but it wasn't your choice. The team folded.
What was that season like for you?
- We did not know that that was coming.
It was actually after the season. I got a
call from one of our front office people.
I was at my old college visiting Coach [Pat] Summitt
Just got a phone call and they said that we’re done.
And I was just in disbelief.
Not even emotional, just shocked.
And so, you kind of lose a generation of players, fans
and young people that could be inspired by,
you know, women playing the game.
So that was hard.
It was hard to transfer, but you have to do it quick.
That is the nature of pro sports. You can get traded.
So I just had to focus on what was next, but I still miss it.
I still miss it out there.
- We talkin' WNBA expansion
- [Lawson:] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The viewership is up, what, 30 percent already so far.
- [Lawson:] Yeah.
- A lot more people are investing in the WNBA.
What do you think the future’s like right now for women's basketball?
- The athlete that you get now is as focused,
as disciplined, as driven as before.
They have unbelievable skill sets and size.
- Mmm.
- Like what some of the 6’5" players are able to do now
is completely different than when I was in the league.
- Well, what's different?
- The 6'5" players now can do everything.
Or are allowed to do everything.
I don't want to knock on the 6'5" players back then.
But they weren't allowed to do what they're allowed to do now.
They were mostly post—
-  Post people. Grabbing boards.
- Yeah, things like that.
- Rim protector.
- And now, they do everything.
Jonquel Jones is a beast. She does everything.
She shoots like 45 percent from three. At 6'6".
Like, that's amazing, you know?
Stewart and what she's able to do.
There's this, the length and the athleticism
and the skill level is really impressive.
Ahh!
- [Laughing]
- So Kara let’s see what you can do here in the Pop-A-Shot, all right?
You’re gonna have 60 seconds.
Gonna ask you some questions as you’re doing this.
See how many you can make, all right?
- All right.
- Let’s get it.
[Digital beeps from game sounding]
- The one athlete dead or alive you’d wanna meet?
- Oh. Wayne Gretzky.
- Best city to visit on the road?
- D.C. Home.
- Pregame snack meal routine.
What’s your favorite pregame snack?
- As a coach, not, I don’t eat a lot.
- [Laughing]
- As a player, probably like some chicken, rice.
- Who're you listening to right now?
- J. Cole.
- 3-on-3 or 5-on-5?
- Right now? In Tokyo? 3-on-3.
- Funniest teammate you ever had?
- Uh, probably a tie between Kalana Greene and Monique Currie.
- Gold medal or WNBA Championship?
- Ooh.
Probably gold medal.
- Dirtiest opponent you’ve faced?
- Lisa Leslie is pretty dirty.
- Best coach you ever had?
- Pat Summitt.
- We’ll end on that note.
- I got triple digits on that one.
- Kara, appreciate you for coming to the pool hall.
Best of luck to you in the Olympics
and best of luck to do with the season, all right?
- Yeah, let’s go.